this is one of the most famous
experiments in linguistics
one of these shapes is called buba the
other is called
kiki which is which this was invented in
1929 using slightly different words
it's been refined over time for most
people the pointy shape is kiki
and the rounded shape is buba the
majority of studies
wow that is that is a that is a lot of
citations the majority of studies
find that pointy shapes are more
associated with
unvoiced plosives and front vowels so
and round shapes are associated more
with voiced plosives nasals and back
vowels so
boo go no okay but that's just english
right we have words like point and
balloon maybe we're just copying
associations from words that we already
know
one of the founders of modern
linguistics has an entire theory named
after him about there being no relation
between the form of a word and what it
represents
but there is a study where english
speakers were given pairs of words in a
language from peru
in each pair one word was for a bird and
one was for a fish
and the english speakers who didn't know
the language who knew nothing even
close to the language they could sort
those words into birds and fish
a little bit better than chance not well
but out of hundreds of people answering
thousands of questions they got 58 right
that is a statistically significant
result and there's another study where
hebrew speakers were given pairs of
chinese characters with opposite
definitions and then they were asked to
match up the characters
and what they meant again slightly
better than chance about 55
right and if people who speak different
languages have even
a slight ability to figure out
completely unfamiliar words
well that raises the question do humans
have some sort of built-in associations
between
sounds and symbols and things in the
real world
buba and kiki have been tested in a lot
of languages and
yeah there seems to be something there
what researchers call a type of
cross-modal correspondence or
sound symbolism correlations between
phonemes the
sounds we make and traits like shape
texture brightness size
or even taste maybe that's down to cross
activation between brain regions
researchers into synesthesia have spent
a long time on that
or it could be repeated association an
elephant makes a deeper sound that a
mouse a large dog
usually barks lower and longer than a
small dog if you shove into a big round
cave it'll reflect back
deep round resonating tones shouting to
a tiny cave with a lot of sharp angles
in it and you'll hear
higher sharper tones something that is
brittle is more like to make a sharp
sound something like
kiki when you hit it or break it or
shatter it something
soft and round is more likely to make a
noise like
i need to stress this is one theory from
a couple of papers don't take this as
gospel it is
right to be skeptical about that plus it
doesn't always work a paper from 1975
shows the results of a bubba kiki style
test on song speakers in papua new
guinea where the results were
like they were picking at random no
preference and in 2017 another test on
shuba speakers in nepal
again no preference the likely reason is
that the nonsense words they chose
could not exist in those languages it'd
be like giving english speakers a test
to choose between
moba and flat you can't start a word
with um
or in english so the choice doesn't make
sense
the frustrating thing is there isn't
much data
on the failures researchers often don't
publish the negative results and besides
it's
very difficult and very expensive to
give linguistic tests to people who've
never
been exposed to any of the major world
languages
but according to all those studies that
buba kiki distinction is true for most
people there may be a link between some
sounds and some real world properties
and that may be why
english speakers were able to
distinguish birds and fish in that
peruvian language
the birds names had more high front
non-rounded vowels
e and e they have more sharp sounds
and while there are plenty of exceptions
birds do have more sharp
beaks and claws than your average fish
does
there's an episode all about this on
enthusiasm the podcast that's run by my
co-author gretchen mcculloch i recommend
it
the link is in the description
you